meagan good to see you hi good to be
with you Megan Kelly returns to Fox News
in her first interview since leaving NBC
though she doesn't discuss her abrupt
exit from the network she does hint her
comeback could come soon enough I'll get
back on that horse soon because this has
been fun so I'll probably get back out
there but right now I'm I'm still
enjoying my my day-to-day life with my
family and friends during the 20 minute
interview on Tucker Carlson tonight she
addresses a variety of topics such as
NBC's lack of external investigation
into Matt Lauer Ronin Pharaohs upcoming
book and the state of journalism today
but perhaps the most interesting nugget
was at the conclusion of the interview
when Carlson asks her what she's learned
over the past year very little I don't
learn so well yeah like Woody Allen I'm
48 years old I've learned nothing I have
learned a thing or two I mean I've what
comes to mind is the goodness of
humanity
you know how the kindness of strangers
just as awful as the media can be actual
humans are awesome and loving and kind
and helpful Kelly has kept a low profile
since her NBC exit but is set to be in
the spotlight again thanks to the
upcoming drama bombshell in which she is
played by Charlize Theron wait am I
gonna be the story no no I'm gonna be
the story no this story this year and a
half two years span that we cover was
the catalyst in many ways for where we
are today and where we're going in the
future and so that to me felt like an
important thing to tap into and also
just really entertaining
Kelly recently said she was in favor of
ferren's casting that's incredibly kind
yeah I haven't heard that so thank you
for telling me that's really sweet
listen we always be try to I think his
actors and his creative storytellers we
try to do all of this with integrity and
so that was always where I came from so
for her to feel good about that I'm sure
it can't be easy for her so I'm
incredibly understanding
[Music]
[Applause]